be yourself
everyone else is already taken
you've got to dance like there's nobody
watching
love like you'll never be hurt
sing like there's nobody listening
and live like it's heaven on earth
you only live once but if you do it
right
once is enough
live as if you were to die tomorrow
learn as if you were to live forever
[Music]
imperfection is beauty
madness is genius
and it's better to be absolutely
ridiculous
than absolutely boring
there are only two ways to live your
life
one is as though nothing is a miracle
the other is as though everything is a
miracle
we are all in the gutter
but some of us are looking at the stars
fairy tales are more than true
not because they tell us that dragons
exist
but because they tell us that dragons
can be beaten
[Music]
i have not failed
i've just found ten thousand ways that
won't work
[Music]
the opposite of love is not hate
it's indifference
the opposite of art is not ugliness
the opposite of faith is not heresy
it's indifference
and the opposite of life is not death
it is never too late to be what you
might have been
life isn't about finding yourself
life is about creating yourself
do what you can with what you have
where you are
success is not final
failure is not fatal
it is the courage to continue that
counts
when one door of happiness closes
another opens
but often we look so long at the closed
door that we do not see the one that has
been opened for us
you can't live your life for other
people
you've got to do what's right for you
even if it hurts some people you love
i can't give you a surefire formula for
success
but i can give you a formula for failure
try to please everybody all the time
happiness is not something ready made
it comes from your own actions
[Music]
attitude is a choice
happiness is a choice
optimism is a choice
kindness is a choice
giving is a choice
respect is a choice
whatever choice you make makes you
choose wisely
if you're reading this
congratulations you're alive
if that's not something to smile about
then i don't know what is
do not go where the path may lead
go instead where there is no path and
leave a trail
if you can't fly then run
if you can't run then walk
if you can't walk then crawl
but whatever you do
you have to keep moving forward
life is too short to waste your time on
people who don't respect appreciate and
value you
don't judge each day by the harvest you
reap but by the seeds that you plant
if you want to be happy
do not dwell in the past
do not worry about the future
focus on living fully in the present
life becomes easier and more beautiful
when we see the good in other people
your hottest times often lead to the
greatest moments of your life
keep going
tough situations build strong people in
the end
keep going
[Music]
you